Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder etwas fragen haben,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen,
ich würde Ihnen gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Carsten Stegemann.
Carsten Stegemann.
Können Sie Ihr Vorname und Nachname langsam und deutlich bestabieren?
Carsten schreibt sich K-A-R-S-T-E-N.
Carsten und Stegemann.
S-T-E-G-I-M-A-N-N.
Stegemann.
Herr Carsten Stegemann.
Ich spreche Ihren Namen richtig aus.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. April 1948.
12. April 1948.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.
Herr Stegemann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich bin jetzt vom Krankenwagen mit dem Krankenwagen gekommen.
Meine Frau hat den Krankenwagen angerufen.
Plötzlich, beim Frühstück, das war vor einer Stunde,
konnte ich meine Kaffee-Tasse nicht mehr halten.
Die war ganz schwach und die Tasse fiel mir aus der Hand.
Meine Frau sagte, dass auch mein Mundwinkel
auf der linken Seite so runtergehangen hat.
Das ist immer noch etwas, aber es ist etwas besser geworden.
Sie sind hier mit dem Krankenwagen gekommen.
Vor einer Stunde konnten Sie
Ihre Kaffee-Tasse nicht mit dem Hand halten.
Ihre Frau hat Ihnen gesagt, dass Sie eine Mundwinkelsenkung haben.
Der Mundwinkel hängt so runter.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Dann ist mir noch aufgefallen, auch meiner Frau,
dass ich sehr schlecht sprechen konnte.
Jetzt kann ich auch noch nicht so richtig gut sprechen.
Es fällt mir schwer, ich muss mich anstrengen.
Aber am Anfang hat meine Frau gesagt,
war meine Stimme sehr verwaschen.
Sie konnte mich kaum verstehen.
Das ist etwas besser geworden, aber noch nicht gut.
Ich verstehe.
Sie haben auch Sprachstörungen mit der Seite.
Sind Sie ein bisschen besser geworden, aber nicht gut.
Nicht gut.
Dann habe ich gemerkt, wollte ich etwas gehen,
zum Krankenwagen gehen.
Das ist aber nicht gut.
Mein linkes Bein ist auch schwach.
Ich kann das linke Bein nicht richtig bewegen.
Okay, linken Bein ist auch schwach.
Verstehe ich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist diese Beschwerden erst einmal oder hat sie nicht schon früher eine Symptome?
Solche Beschwerden habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Mir ist in letzter Zeit häufiger schwindelig.
Besonders wenn ich mal Treppen steige oder ich wohne im zweiten Stock,
dann ist mir manchmal schwindelig.
Da muss ich auch eine Pause machen.
Aber so etwas wie jetzt habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben eine Gangstörungen an linken Bein.
Ja, ich habe richtig verstanden.
Ja.
Sie haben nur linken Seite dieser Probleme.
Ja, auf der linken Seite.
Ich konnte die Kaffeetasse mit links,
konnte ich die Kaffeetasse plötzlich nicht mehr festhalten.
Und meine Frau sagte,
im linken Mundwinkel sei irgendwas nicht in Ordnung.
Und linke Bein ist sehr schwach.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Ja, haben Sie Kraftverlust am Bein?
Ja, ja.
Auch am Bein.
Ich kann da nicht gut drauf stehen.
Da knick ich weg, knick ich ein.
Okay, Bein und Arm.
Ja.
Haben Sie bewusste Einverlust?
Nein.
Kein Wobbesterin verloren.
Haben Sie See- oder Hörstörung während dieser Zeit?
Ich trage ein Hörgerät.
Auf beiden Ohren habe ich Hörgeräte.
Das kann ich jetzt noch nicht so richtig...
Aber ich glaube nicht, das stört mich nicht so sehr.
Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Seit einem Stunde hatten Sie keine Hörprobleme,
aber schon haben Sie ein Hörgerät getragen.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Vergesslichkeit oder könnten Sie nicht gut konzentrieren?
Also in der letzten Stunde, seitdem ich das habe,
bin ich sehr aufgeregt und sehr unter Stress.
Aber normalerweise habe ich ein gutes Gedächtnis.
Das kann ich mich gut erinnern.
Das ist bisher noch niemandem aufgefallen.
Mein Gedächtnis ist gut.
Sie haben gesagt, während der Frühstück
hatten Sie diese Probleme.
Was machen Sie während der Frühstück?
Es gibt es besonders.
Nein, ich habe eine Scheibe Brot gegessen
mit Marmelade und wollte gerade meine Tasse Kaffee trinken.
Und dann konnte ich die Kaffee-Tasse plötzlich nicht mehr festhalten.
Dann wäre ich schwach.
Okay, verstehe.
Sind Sie nicht empfindlich oder lärmempfindlich?
Nein.
Herr Steigaman, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemeine zustande stellen.
Haben Sie Verstärken durst bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht abgenommen oder so genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Füste?
Ja, husten.
Ich habe, glaube ich, meinen Arzt gesagt,
ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Ich muss häufig husten
und nehme auch ein Medikament ein.
Aber Luftnot, wenn ich Treppen steige,
in letzter Zeit habe ich eben gesagt, da wird mir manchmal schwindelig.
Und da habe ich auch dann manchmal schlechter Luft.
Ja, da bekomme ich schlechter Luft.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Seit vielleicht 4 Wochen, 5 Wochen.
Seit 4, 5 Wochen.
Bestätigt die Luftnot nur bei Belastung, beim Treppensteigen?
Ja, ja.
Können Sie vielleicht legen oder brauchen Sie ein paar Kissen?
Ich brauche immer ein Kissen.
Ein Kissen brauche ich, das ist notwendig.
Aber schon lange seid, brauchen Sie nur ein Kissen?
Ja, das brauche ich schon seit einigen Jahren.
Einigen Jahre.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlsanke oder was?
Trosserlassen muss ich so ein bis zweimal in der Nacht.
Da war ich aber schon mal bei einem Urologen.
Der hat die Prostata angeschaut.
Und hat gesagt, ja, die Prostata ist zwar etwas vergrößert,
aber aus seiner Sicht muss man jetzt erst mal noch nichts machen.
Ich kann danach auch wieder gut einschlafen.
Das ist ganz gut.
Und wegen Stuhlgang hatte ich vor 2 Jahren eine Darmspiegelung.
Aber eine Vorsorge-Darmspiegelung.
Aber das war in Ordnung.
Da war nichts Auffälliges.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stuhlfrost?
Oder vielleicht Nachschweiß, Kaltschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal im Urlaub?
Im Urlaub. Ich mache viel Urlaub.
Im Sommer war ich jetzt in Schweden.
Bin ich in Schweden gereist, mit der Eisenbahn.
Ich war auch im Mai in Spanien 2 Wochen.
Da bin ich allerdings mit dem Flugzeug hingeflogen.
Das war dieses Jahr bis hier meine Urlaube.
Ich habe mich in der Urlaube geflogen.
Das war sehr schön aus.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Außer chronische Brunschitis und Vergrößerung des Prostates
haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Seit ungefähr 15 Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie denn?
Ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Da nehme ich einmal ein Kandisatan.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Da hinter steht 8.
Ich nehme morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe Tablette.
Ich nehme noch ein Medikament.
Die Tüde Ha.
Soll ich das Buch stabilieren?
Ja, bitte.
D-Y-T-I-D-E.
Da hinter ein großes Ha.
Da nehme ich eine am Tag.
Das wirkt über die Niere, hat mein Arzt gesagt.
Davon muss ich mehr Wasser lassen.
Mehr Wasser lassen.
Das wird dann auch nicht mehr entlasten.
Und den Blutdruck senken.
Sie haben gesagt, seit mehreren Jahren
leiden Sie an chronische Branche.
Ja, das ist so.
Das ist jetzt so seit einigen Jahren.
Bis vor fünf Jahren habe ich ziemlich viel geraucht.
Da habe ich 30 Jahre geraucht.
35 Jahre habe ich eine Schachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Vor fünf Jahren habe ich mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Wow, das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Vielleicht etwas spät, aber es fühlen wir mich damit auch besser.
Ich nehme ein.
Das bin ich aber ehrlich, dass ich das nicht immer mache.
Ich soll es regelmäßig nehmen.
Wie heißt das?
Boudi Sonit.
Das ist so Kapseln.
Da kommt ein Pulver aus dem Apparat.
Ich muss das einatmen, inhalieren.
Das soll ich zumindest im Winter nehmen.
Wenn ich mehr Branche habe.
Zweimal am Tag.
Ich mache es unregelmäßig, ehrlich gesagt.
Okay, nur Winter.
Im Sommer geht es mir eigentlich
mit den Brontchen ganz gut.
Aber jetzt ist es hauptsächlich in der Winterzeit.
Da ist das häufig so, dass ich da auch starke Branche habe.
Das ist im Augenblick, aber finde ich geht das.
Das war schon mal schlimmer.
Dann habe ich noch hohe Kollisterien seit zehn Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch ein Medikament.
Wer will Medikament nehmen?
Das heißt Rosovastatin.
Das ist jetzt so seit zwei Jahren.
Früher habe ich ein anderes Medikament genommen.
Aber Rosovastatin vertrag ich gut.
Da hinter steht 20.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Manchmal habe ich in letzter Zeit auch so bemerkt,
gerade wenn ich so treppen steige
und ich muss Pause machen,
dass ich manchmal, wenn ich dann so ein bisschen schwindel habe,
so ein unregelmäßiges Herzschlag habe.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich zu meinem Hausarzt gehen,
dass das mal untersucht wird.
Aber das habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Würden Sie sich schon einmal operieren?
Ja, als Kind.
Da wurde ich am Blinddamm operiert.
Da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Vor sieben Jahren wurde ich links
eine künstliche Hüfte bekommen.
Auf der linken Seite.
Schwere Arthrose hatte ich in der Hüfte.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde ich neue Linsen bekommen.
Im Auge.
Weil ich grauen Star hatte.
Wer ging gerne?
Ja, ich habe einen kleinen.
Wer ging grauen Star?
Ja.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen nach Ihre Luftnot.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Sie geschwollene Beine haben?
Manchmal im Sommer, wenn es warm ist,
dann sind die manchmal etwas dicker,
aber nicht sehr stark.
Manchmal ist es nicht so,
Mein Arzt sagt, das kommt vom Herz.
Deswegen hat er mehr auch diese Tablette verschrieben.
Dieses Dietüde Haar.
Was über die Niere wirkt.
Er sagt, das wäre ganz gut.
Ich glaube auch,
dass etwas verbessert hat.
Diese Wassersammlung in den Beinen.
Ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Gewohnheit erzählen.
Sie haben mit dem Rachen vor fünf Jahren
aufgehört.
Trinken Sie Alkohol regelmäßig?
Ich trinke vielleicht so.
Da haben wir mal 3 Glas Wein pro Woche.
3 Glas Wein pro Woche.
Bitte nehmen Sie mir nächste Frage.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Nein.
Jetzt werde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie geschichten.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Mein Vater hatte einen schweren Schlaganfall
und mit 82 Jahren
und ist daran verstorben.
Das tut mir weiss.
Die Mutter, die ist 96 Jahre alt,
lebt im Pflegeheim.
Sie hat eine gewisse Altersverwirrtheit.
Altersdemenz, glaube ich.
Sie hat auch ein schwaches Herz.
Herzschwäche.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, eine ist 72 Jahre alt.
Sie hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Vor vier Jahren hatte die Schwester Darmkrebs.
Tut mir leid.
Sie hat einen Bruder, der ist 74 Jahre alt.
Der hat Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Bei dem wurde auch ein Katedra gemacht.
Da wurde versucht,
den Herzrhythmus wieder zu regulieren.
Aber das ist leider nicht erfolgreich gewesen.
Deswegen muss der einige andere Medikamente noch nehmen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Die sind 40 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund.
Wir haben es gleich geschafft.
Ich habe ein paar Informationen zu Ihrer Sozialstatus.
Sie sind jetzt im Rensner.
Aber waren Sie früher?
Ich war früher Lehrer.
An einem Gymnasium.
Für Deutsche Kinder.
Sie sind verheiratet.
Sie leben mit Ihrer Frau.
Haben Sie Stress?
Nein.
Herr Stiegemann, jetzt sind wir mit dem Gespräch fertig.
Ich werde eine Körperversuchung machen.
Dann habe ich Blut für das Lebo abgemacht.
Ich habe eine kleine Schwester.
Ich werde eine große Versuchung.
Ich habe Blut für das Lebo abgetrilscht.
Eine DAVID- столько mainland Zhi-Tie-Komputertomografie
schaffen soll.
Bei der Basis Olaf kommt ich zur !!!
Und scє hier die Situation!
WO conducting Sie Michelle?
Nein.
Okay, dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Denken Sie an die Übersetzung der Patientensprache in Fachsprache, Fachbegriffe.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn ich ein paar Minuten bekomme, freue ich mich sehr.
Und die anderen Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben, haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Die können wir dann besprechen. Vielleicht noch ergänzende Fragen.
Darf ich etwas fragen? Bitte.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder Narus mit selbst bekannt?
Sind mir nicht bekannt.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Brust-Schmerzen besonders während Treppen aussteigen?
Nein, Brust-Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Wurden Sie EKG oder Kardiologen untersuchen durchgeführt?
Bis jetzt nicht. EKG schon mal früher, aber in letzter Zeit nicht.
Aber beim Kardiologen war ich noch nicht bisher.
Dieser Spittel habe ich euch jetzt auch erst seit einigen Wochen.
Und ich gehe nicht immer sofort zum Arzt. Ich warte immer gerne.
Danke.
Guten Tag. Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Wie lange dauert Ihre Beschwerden?
Hat Ihre Frau im Besonderen um Mund-Lib blaufarbe bemerkt?
Blaue Farbe?
Nein. Die Beschwerden sind jetzt seit einer guten Stunde.
Vor einer Stunde haben sie angefangen,
dass ich plötzlich meine Kaffeetasse nicht mehr halten konnte
und meine Stimme nicht so gut war.
Jetzt ist sie immer noch nicht so richtig gut.
Die anderen Beschwerden sind seit einigen Wochen
beim Treppensteigen, dass ich da manchmal so schwindelig werde
und auch etwas Luftnot habe, aber keine Schmerzen.
Und Farbe verwendet? Keine Bemerkts?
Nein. Die Veränderung hat es meiner Frau nicht aufgefallen.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Seit wann haben Sie Ihre Herzschlagen bemerkt?
Erstens.
Dass der Herzschlag manchmal unregelmäßig ist?
Ja, auch so vor vielleicht vier Wochen.
Während der Luftnot?
Ja, Luftnot.
Ich habe es dann auch mal so versucht,
bei einem Puls zu fühlen abends im Bett.
Und dann habe ich auch bemerkt,
er ist nicht so ganz regelmäßig.
Okay.
Seit wann tragen Sie Hergerät?
Bürgeräute trage ich schon bestimmt acht Jahre.
Ja.
Entschuldigung, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 76.
76, okay.
Danke schön.
Bitte.
Ja, eine Frage.
Ist der Blutdruck mit dem Kommandeur gut eingestellt?
Der Blutdruck?
Ja, ich war jetzt zuletzt bei meinem Arzt vor drei Monaten.
Da war er ganz gut.
Manchmal misst auch meine Frau den Blutdruck bei mir.
Aber in letzter Zeit haben wir das eher selten gemacht.
Also nicht jeden Tag oder so,
vielleicht einmal pro Woche oder so.
Und da war er zuletzt, glaube ich, 140, 145, 90.
Und 150?
Ja, 140 bis 145 zu 90.
Okay.
Haben Sie beinahe Zentrumen, Teilbeutsch, Gepäu, oder Grippe ein?
Nein.
Hab ich nicht gespürt.
Kinder.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Ja, bitte.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Hüftgelenkproblem.
Nach dem Hüftgelenkproblem,
treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, nicht so richtig Sport.
Ich versuche spazieren zu gehen.
Das mache ich, ich versuche mich regelmäßig zu bewegen
an der frischen Luft.
Da macht die Hüfte mir auch keine großen Beschwerden.
Aber richtig Sport,
manchmal nehme ich eine kleine Handel zu Hause
und mache etwas Handel, Gewichttraining, Krafttraining,
aber nicht richtig Sport mehr.
Das habe ich früher gemacht, aber jetzt schon seit einigen Jahren nicht mehr.
Aber dafür haben Sie Sport getroffen?
Wie früher.
Früher habe ich Sport getrieben.
Okay, danke schön.
Wir können anfangen.
Ja, können wir anfangen.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herr Karsten Steigmann.
Er ist 78 Jahre alt und am 12.04.1948 geboren.
Er ist 76 Jahre alt.
Er ist 76 Jahre alt und am 12.04.1948 geboren.
Er ist 178 cm groß und wiegt 80 kg.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns wegen von seit einigen Jahren
der 5.Jährige.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns wegen von seit einigen Jahren der 5.Jährige.
Paräse an linken Arm und linken Bein auf Wund Winkelsenkung und Disfony 4.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind diese Beschwerden beim Früchten plötzlich aufgetreten.
Danach ist er mit Krankenwagen ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Ausserdem klagt er über Disfony bei Belastung seit 4 bis 5 Wochen bestehend.
Auch manchmal Taikardee, die Fragen so disfangehe, Parästhesie, bewusstsein Verlust,
Verneint, auch Zerstörung und Verneint, aber er hat schon eine Hörgerät gefragt.
Der Stuhlgang ist unaufhällig?
Der Stuhlgang ist normal. Vor 2 Jahren würde ihm eine Darmspiegelung durchgeführt, aber nur für Vorsorge.
Eine Vorsorge-Colonoskopie?
Gut, die Weinordnung.
Hat der Patient chronisch erkrankt?
Ja, er leidet an, dass ich seit 5 Jahren und ich seit 15 Jahren und meine Prostatiperpläse habe.
Bei der Operation Anamnese erwähnte er eine Appendokopie mit Sein Lebensjahr und vor 7 Jahren total hüfte Prostatee.
Wie kennen Sie den Begriff für Hüfte?
Ja, Coxatrose.
Vor 7 Jahren erfolgt eine Endoprothese, links der Hüfte bei Coxatrose.
Vor 5 Jahren würde ihm eine Hüfte, links der Hüfte bei Coxatrose.
Vor 5 Jahren würde ihm eine Linzenopie wegen Grauenstahl, wegen Katarakt.
Bei der Medikament Anamnese gab es die Einnahme von Kandan Santran, Sartan, 8 mg, einmal Morgen, halbe Abend, die Tüdeha, einmal Morgen auf Budezonit,
2 Mal am Tag, aber besonders im Winter, nicht regelmäßig.
Und wegen Hypercholesterinämie?
Ja, rosevast nimmt er gegen Cholesterinämie rosevastetin 20 mg seit 2 Jahren einmal Abend.
Sagen Sie ruhig, wegen Hypercholesterinämie, erhöhtes Cholesterinämie, er nimmt rosevastetin 20 mg einmal abends.
Gut, das ist schon mal das.
Wie gibt es bei den Patienten sonstige Auffälligkeiten bezüglich der Familienanamnese?
Ja, es gibt viele wichtige Informationen bei der Familienanamnese.
Seine Vater ist an Schlagapoplex gestorben.
Wie alt war der Vater da?
Mit 82 Jahren.
Im Alter von 82 Jahren ist der Vater an einem Apoplex- oder apoplektischen Insult verstorben.
Und die Mutter?
Seine Mutter leidet an Herzinsuffizienz und Demons.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
Sie ist 96 Jahre alt.
Gut, gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er hat eine Schwester und eine Bruder.
Sie leidet an arteriellen Hypertomene und Kolonkarsinone.
Sie ist 72 Jahre alt und seine Bruder leidet an Herzrhythmische Törungen.
Er würde ihm eine Herzkatheter durchgeführt, aber leider war das nicht erfolgt.
Er nimmt jetzt Medikament gegen Herzkatheter.
Wahrscheinlich wurde versucht eine Applation zu machen.
Die Applation war nicht erfolgreich.
Hat der Patient über Schwindel geklagt?
Ja, er klagt häufig über Schwindel.
Besonders, wenn er eine Dispene hat.
Aber während dieser Situation hat er keine Schwindel.
Er hat in den letzten Wochen beobachtet, dass er beim Treppensteigen
schnell vertigo bekommt und eine Belastungsdispene.
Er hat beobachtet, dass sein Puls etwas unregelmäßig ist.
Er beobachtet eine Arithmie im Puls.
Das würde ich als wichtig in der Schilderung ansehen.
Diese Information ist sehr wichtig, weil das Risikofaktor ist.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist eine transitorische iskämische Attacke.
Er hat nur seit einer Stunde diese Beschwerde.
Diese Beschwerden sind mit der Zeit ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber sie sind noch vorhanden.
Wir wissen nicht, ob sie in 24 Stunden gehen.
Oder sie werden schlimmer?
Es gibt viele Ursache für diese Patienten.
Diese Patient leidet an Hypercholestronomie und Artérielle Hypertonie.
Er hat auf Herzrhythmische Störungen und Erwand unregelmäßige Herzschlagen.
Das sind schon sehr wichtige Faktoren.
Der Patient hat noch einen langjährigen Nikotin-Abusus.
Er hat vor fünf Jahren eingestellt.
Aber der 45-Jahre-Package ist ein bestimmter Risikofaktor.
Vielen Dank.
Sie haben sich sehr gut ausgedrückt.
Ich würde Ihnen noch ein raten, wenn ein Patient mit dem Rettungswagen in die Ambulanz gebracht wird.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich gesagt, dass sie auf Apoplex verdacht.
Sie müssen sich ein Bild machen, direkt in der Ambulanz, über seine Vitalzeichen.
Ich würde sofort bei Ihnen den Blutdruck messen.
Ich würde SPO2 messen und ein Monitor EKG machen.
Dann können Sie vielleicht schon mal sehen, wie ist der Blutdruck?
Muss ich da intervenieren?
Oder kann ich erst mal sagen, Blutdruck ist erst mal okay?
Wie ist die Sauerstoffsetzung bei den Patienten?
Und hat er eventuell gravierende Rhythmusstörungen, die ich schon im Monitor EKG auch sehe?
Oder hat einen Sinusrhythmus?
Diese drei Sachen würde ich auf alle Fälle bei so einem Patienten gleich zu Anfang machen.
Ich würde mir die Vitalwerte kontrollieren, wenn der Patient schildert.
Seit einer Stunde ist mir die Kaffeetasse aus der Hand gefallen.
Ich habe eine Schwäche im Arm, ich habe nicht richtig sprechen können.
Mein Mundwinkel hängt ein bisschen, mein Bein ist schwach.
Da würde ich dann sofort erst mal sagen, stehe ich mir gut, dass Sie zu uns gekommen sind.
Ich möchte zunächst erst mal noch einmal den Blutdruck messen
und den Sauerstoff messen und ein EKG machen.
Das ist für den Patienten gut, da hat er das Gefühl auch.
Die Ärztin kümmert sich um mich, sehr Empathie.
Und für sie ist es wichtig, weil der Oberarzt die garantiert danach fragt.
Ich hätte sie sonst gefragt, was machen die Vitalwerte bei den Patienten?
Dann haben Sie gesagt, ich habe die Vitalwerte kontrolliert.
Der Blutdruck war ganz gut, war 140 zu 90.
SPO 2 war 93 und im EKG ein Sinus-Rhythmus, aber vereinzelte Extrasistolen.
Mehr konnte ich noch nicht sagen, aber zumindest keine gravierenden Werte,
sodass Sie die Anamnese fortsetzen können.
Sie mussten nicht intervenieren.
Das würde ich immer bei so einem Patienten machen,
mit Verdacht auf frischem Apoplex,
mit Torachschmerz, zum Beispiel, oder mit akuter Dispnell.
Dass sie diese Werte bitte messen oder akuten starken Kopfschmerzen.
Nicht, dass ein Patient vor ihnen sitzt, die befragen ihn 20 Minuten
und der Patient hat eine hypertone Krise.
Das wäre für den Patienten nicht so gut.
Der sollte dann doch frühzeitig dann auch Hilfe bekommen.
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe 2. Februar einen Termin.
Wo? Bei welcher Erstekammer?
Düsseldorf.
2. Februar in Düsseldorf, das wissen Sie, da ist Karneval.
Karneval, kennen Sie Karneval?
Ja, ich kenne Karneval.
Ich weiß nicht, wann Karneval ist.
Aber ich glaube, der Höhepunkt des Karnevals ist etwas später, glaube ich,
Ende Februar, Mitte Ende Februar.
Aber unabhängig davon.
Gut, ja prima.
Aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl, das machen Sie gut.
Sie kennen viele Fachbegriffe und das ist gut.
Sie müssen sich dann an Sie erinnern, an die Fachbegriffen.
Gut, vielleicht sehen wir uns bis dahin noch mal wieder.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal sagen, dass ich die nächsten 2 Wochen
kein Training mache.
Also nächste Woche ist ja hier Weihnachten.
Es ist ja Feiertag.
Und in 2 Wochen ist auch Feiertag, da ist das neue Jahr.
Aber in 3 Wochen wieder, da können wir uns wieder treffen.
Ja?
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen
einen anderen Teil, den man eine gute Zeit und dann sehen wir uns
im nächsten Jahr wieder.
8. Januar, meinen Sie 8. Januar, Dienstag?
Ja, nein, also ich glaube, was ist der 1. Januar,
ist glaube ich ein Donnerstag, stimmt das?
Ja.
1. Januar, Donnerstag passt.
Ja, dann sagen wir 8. Januar.
8. Januar, Dienstag.
Wieder um 6 Uhr, 18 Uhr.
Feier Weihnachten und ich wünsche Ihnen
ein gutes neues Jahr.
Ja, ich Ihnen allen auch, ja.
Alles Gute, alles Gute.
Tschüss, ciao.